i dans des fonds 10 a voulu mettre en
avant les féroces girl et moelleux le
concept puisque nous sommes un club avec
plus de 120 femmes qui pratiquons du vtt
loisirs et il a voulu profiter de la
présentation des du tout où mettre en
avant la section des féroces girl et m'a
gentiment demandé si nous pouvions être
que les hôtesses cette année alors je
suppose que si on vous a proposé ces
faits cet honneur là c'est que le
cyclisme féminin martiniquaise se porte
plutôt bien et qu'il est en progression
assez importante
oui effectivement puisque ya il ya eu le
tout le tour féminin pour les filles la
semaine dernière et au niveau des
féroces girl nous essayons du mieux que
nous pouvons de développer la pratique
en tout cas un autre niveau du vtt
loisirs et en compétition effet il ya il
ya de plus en plus de filles et même au
niveau de la section de l'association
féroce nous avons une dizaine de filles
qui font de la compétition et chaque
club en martinique essaye justement
d'avoir deux ou trois filles ce qui
permet d'avoir un peloton d'une
trentaine d'un fils chaque fois qu'elles
font des causses alors effectivement le
tour cycliste de martinique est destiné
principalement aux hommes mais vous êtes
quand même là en arrière-scène
l'efferalgan sont là aussi sur le tour
puisque depuis six ans nous sommes dans
la caravane publicitaire donc avec les
partenaires de notre club et c'est avec
plaisir mais que nous le faisons un
puisque quand je fais la demande
j'ai un effectif trop élevé pour le tout
et puis toutes celles qui ne sont pas
sur la caravane sont au bord des routes
pour supporter les coureurs du club mais
aussi tous les coureurs de martinique et
les étrangers